now the first thing I want to do where I
want to begin its just with what we did
yesterday because I kind of gave me an
explanation
but I sort of stopped short of and I
realized this when people ask me
questions later
just showing you okay what are the steps
to go through when you just want to work
out the answer okay so if you remember
there were two main shapes two main
prisms that we were after the first one
was the rectangular prism okay so we
won't deal on this too long I just want
to double check that you're okay mean if
they're working and how you set this out
okay question well we're going to be on
page 218 shortly but that's when we get
into today's stuff I just want to tidy
up from yesterday
now rectangular prism okay you're always
going to get three dimensions for okay
now with regard to drawing it's a very
good question
do you have to draw them you don't have
to but I mean like just personally I'm a
math teacher I find it so much easier
whenever God drawing they're even it's
not beautiful like it's got the right
measurements on there I find it a lot
easier so understanding get the right
answer okay so in that way I guess the
choice is yours you have to draw a
diagram no I think you're really hot now
on this rectangular prism rather than
put numbers like 2 3 4 5 or something
like that on yes I'm really very very
general about it ok so I'm going to call
this front one be for breath ok that's
how bored it is this one going off into
the distance I'll call that L for length
so there's one distance there and
another distance there
yes yeah okay so we're gonna get onto
volume in a second but let me let me say
hi to you put on there pretty sure it's
on cool now if I wanna if I'm gonna
learn what the surface area is remember
that's how I can get all over faces all
added up together okay so let's just
have a look at the three faces that we
can see on this side right for instance
this one here in the front that's going
to be brent times higher right so I'm
doing surface area Yeah right so I'm
gonna have H times B now give me this
one okay but then there's one on the
back
remember we talked about this right so
if I put my daughter blinds in you've
got that one over there and it's exactly
the same so I'm gonna get two of them
okay all right now let's have a look at
this side that's facing the right okay
that way right
so it's L units this way and tall is it
it's it's H tall right whatever unit
that might be centimeters meters
whatever okay so if I want to work out
that face there it's gonna be H times L
but just like this face there's two of
them
right so I'll say two of those and
there's one last one we've done this one
we've done this one I suppose we should
do the top or the bottom they're the
same but they're okay so the bottom for
instance is B times L it's still another
rectangle okay so I'll say B times L
just like every other face there's two
of them
okay there we go now if you remember
back to them we were doing algebra
because you've got twos here everything
is multiplied by two so you can just
write one so you out the front and put
brackets and that way you don't have to
double everything you can just do it all
in one hit
hey good there is the surface area of a
rectangular prism done okay so if you
get given a question right and they give
you actual numbers here like two four
seven something like that okay all you
need to do is put the numbers in the
right spots that's all okay quickly
let's revise the triangular prism which
is the other 3d shape we were looking at
okay so let me just draw one so let's
see yeah actually don't just look back
at the kinds of examples you've got I'm
just thinking to myself three four are
they all equal lateral is the pressure
mentally they are out there they are I
saw my sausage which ones
yeah later on later on so let's just
think if this triangle on the front I
think they're mostly equilateral okay so
I guess this would be an equilateral
triangular prism I'll let you have a
think of that what would happen it what
would change if it wasn't equilateral
okay then anyway there's the front face
and if we draw some lines out like that
there's the rest of it I guess
okay so there's my triangle in prison
right now I'm going to approach it in
much the same way I need some
measurements though don't know just like
here I had three measurements I'm gonna
have three here right so I'm gonna call
them very similar ones I'm gonna call
this one again B but this time B for
base because that's what usually same
triangle what else do we need to work
out the area we made that that height
there right okay so you've got this
height here but it's kind of important
that's perpendicular so drawing a little
wide angle there so you know it's a
perpendicular height and then I think we
said like okay good now we're trying to
do sub serie right so just like the full
we'll take a one step at a time okay now
it's a triangular prism so let's start
with triangle right right in the front
here okay it's base there's a height
what's the area now for triangles base
times height on to isn't it right but
how many triangles are there to do the
surface there's two there's one on the
front and one on the back yeah
so it's actually two times and you'll
see those will cancel in a second okay
now we've done triangles what other
kinds of faces do we have yeah so I've
got one I should I should do it in a
different color okay I don't one from
this side one from this side of in one
of the dentin okay so I've got three of
these rectangles so three times now
what's the area of each of the
rectangles
now it's gonna be there's gonna be
lengths involved right because the
rectangular means that length there but
if you for example if I just drew the
base the bottom part right it would look
like this you see I'm just taking that
pot ignoring that's the lines there you
got be this way and you've got L this
way right so what's the area of that
writing yeah that's right
Oh B right now he's the useful thing and
this is why we I was [ __ ] around as to
whether it's been collateral or not
right because all of these sides are
equal they're right that means this is
the same as the base right and so is
this all the rectangles all three of
them they're all same so this is what
I'm gonna get base times height there
you go that's a triangular prism
okay supposing all of the sides of the
triangle are the same now please do tell
me later on if you get to an exercise
the one on the page I'm looking at they
are all equilateral if they're not then
that's a bit different and we'll have a
look at that one again but this is just
revision from yesterday